the show begins in thailand's top-rated
school rita high it is considered the
hardest school to get into as many thai
leaders and sports persons are its
alumni the school itself is strict and
is divided into several sections of
students according to their academic
capabilities the students belonging to
section 1 have privileges like no others
they get better washrooms more food
portions better dorms and a free pass to
get out of any trouble they make in
other words they're all going to become
fat criminals as the section number
increases the privileges decrease the
last section is section 8 which is
notoriously famous for being the class
of the dumb they get little to no
academic privilege a rustic bathroom
fewer food portions and a dorm that they
have to share with 10 more people the
protagonist pang is the last student of
section 8. he is officially the dumbest
guy at rita high and is bullied by all
his only friend is nak who is from
section 1 and is named after a terrible
video game because of his influence pang
was given a nicer dorm to share with him
despite being from very different social
classes they always have each other's
back nak frequently tries to tutor pang
so he can also move to higher sections
but pang likes to complain about the
unfair system rather than studying one
afternoon he pretends to be a section 1
student to get better food but he
accidentally drops his plate on a
student named wave he is an arrogant
genius who can solve math and computer
problems in seconds without a calculator
wave orders paying to clean his shoe or
he will tell the principal that he is
pretending to be of a higher section
just then principal latta intervenes and
asks them what the problem is pang is
about to be caught before nak comes to
his aid and lies that he is one of the
good students even though pang's batch
is missing lada believes knack and tells
him to go next week the mid-semester
test is going to be held it is the most
crucial test of their school life
because the selected few will be
upgraded to the gifted class it is a
special section of students who receive
advantages over everyone else in the
school even section one they are given
apartments instead of dorms free health
checkups every month their education is
funded by the school and they are made
to attend special classes unlike the
normal students every student who has
been in the gifted program over the
years has achieved unattainable heights
of success hence the entire school is
studying hard for the midterms knack is
worried for his friend knowing that he
might get kicked out of the school if he
fails again hence the duo decides to
steal the midterm papers they are
successful in doing so but the questions
seem odd to knack he thinks they're too
easy considering that they decide who
gets to be in the gifted group
eventually the day of the test arrives
pang has brought a cheat sheet with all
the answers but he doesn't want to use
them halfway through the test a noise
plays on the speakers followed by
someone asking the students to write
their thoughts about evolution on the
back page pang starts doing as
instructed but strangely enough the
other students didn't seem to have heard
the message in the following scene a
crowd has gathered in front of the
notice board looking for their ranks to
pang's utmost surprise he has been
selected for the gifted program and at
the same time knack hasn't nack is
clearly upset and believes that pang
somehow cheated him so he could get into
the program at night they talk about
everything and he pretends that the
results don't bother him pang is glad
that his friend is understanding unaware
that knack has started to hate him the
next day he walks into the gifted class
for the first time the arrogant topper
wave has also made it into the class
pang instantly makes friends with a guy
named om who used to be in section 2.
moments later a teacher named mr palm
enters the class he is a special trainer
assigned to assist the gifted students
only he shows them a presentation about
the rules one has to follow now that
they are a part of something extra the
most crucial rule is that they are not
allowed to talk about the things that
happen in class to the people outside
throughout the presentation pang notices
weird equations popping up on the screen
that everyone ignores at the end of the
class pom shows them a math question and
asks them for the answer the question
makes no sense but everyone seems to
know the answer other than paying this
is because the question is related to
the equations that were shown throughout
the presentation the others were able to
process it in their minds and form an
answer but not paying before the class
is dismissed mr palm assigns them to
find out why they're in the classroom he
doesn't explain the question further and
leaves the students confused a few days
later pang and knack get into an
argument because pang doesn't tell them
anything about the gifted class nak
thinks pang has made friends with wave
and forgotten him wave hears this and
provokes knack even more this causes an
altercation and wave falls unconscious
in the following scene peng and knack
are in the principal's office they are
about to be punished when palm comes to
peng's rescue since he is one of the
gifted his punishment is waived but
knack's punishment is doubled as a
result peng tries to help his friend but
knack is not grateful at all he pushes
pang and the two get into a fight in
front of the principal it ends when they
declare that they are no longer each
other's friends after that pang moves
out of his old dorm room and into the
new apartment the gifted students have
picked up on the strange curriculum they
are being taught in class one evening
they gather in the computer lab to
discuss what the management wants from
the gifted they agree that something
unnatural is happening to all of them
suddenly wave arrives and reveals that
he knows what is going on he has hacked
into mr palm's laptop and has access to
his webcam they watch palm talking to
the school's director about them he
praises wave for figuring out his gift
quicker than everyone else he further
explains that wave has the power to hack
into any computer or electronic system
with just a touch
everyone is shocked but before they ask
wave if it is true they are interrupted
by the school's director he turns the
laptop towards him assuming that wave
and the group are watching him he is
proud of them for being curious and
explains that they weren't chosen
randomly all animals are constantly
evolving to fit into the environment and
the same goes for humans they have been
chosen because they are more evolved
than their normal classmates they
possess supernatural and superhuman
abilities that stem from their
personalities and behavior he asks them
to rest assured because they are not
being experimented upon instead their
capabilities will be polished in the
gifted program so they can grow up and
do things for the betterment of
humankind as a whole after the meeting
the gifted are in shock pang doesn't
believe the director because he sees
himself as an ordinary guy the next day
the students are asked if they have
found their abilities everyone raises
their hands except pang and another guy
the rest tell everyone about their
powers the first guy can imitate any
skill just by watching a video of
someone doing it then there are a pair
of twins who are in sync and can feel
each other's pain that's a terrible
power
third is a girl named nam tan who can
hear and see things associated with
objects she proves her ability by
touching a pencil box and revealing
where it was a few days ago om is the
last person to showcase his ability but
it turns out he hasn't figured it out
yet and thinks making people laugh is
his specialty later nem tan asks him for
her pen that she lent him earlier in
class she is heartbroken upon
discovering that he lost it because it
was a gift from someone special om also
feels bad and wishes the pen would
reappear just when he says that
something tings inside his pencil box
but he doesn't check it during the lunch
break ohm's classmate fred gives him a
bag and asks him to keep it safe it
contains the test papers for a test
tomorrow the principal catches him with
the bag and checks it to his surprise
she gives it back because the papers
have vanished the incident makes him
register that his superpower is making
things disappear he shows his ability to
his classmates in the next class and
impresses them mr palm wants him to be
careful because he doesn't know how to
bring the things back into existence yet
when om is in the bathroom that day he
is approached by fred who wants the test
papers back ohm claims that they
disappeared but fred refuses to believe
him he is about to get violent before om
vanishes him in the heat of the moment
he regrets it instantly and runs away
the next day the news about fred's
disappearance spreads around the school
ohm doesn't tell anyone about his
involvement until wave hacks the cctv
footage and shows the entire class that
he was responsible for the disappearance
afraid that he will do the same to other
people ohm runs away and stays in the
computer lab for the rest of the day
hours later peng finds him and asks him
to at least try to bring the missing
things back om has lost all hope until
namtan shows him that her pen magically
reappeared in her pencil box this means
if he really wants to get something back
he can the three go to the bathroom
stall where om tries his best to bring
fred back initially nothing works but
then they hear a noise coming from a
stall to their relief it is amber heard
taking a poop in a toilet this time and
not on a bed just kidding fred has
returned and even though he is a little
bit shaken he is doing fine in the next
class om shows his classmates the
progress he made in controlling his
power mr palm encourages everyone to do
the same because they have only just
started to see the beginning stage of
their abilities while walking down the
hallways that day own bumps into fred to
his surprise fred doesn't seem to
recognize him he is distracted by other
things so he dismisses it for the moment
the gifted spend the next few days
trying to explore more of themselves
namtan shows the most progress and can
now tell who the owner of a thing is
just by touching it however she has a
weakness that whenever she uses the
power her blood pressure rises to a
dangerous level mr pom talks to her
mother who discloses that high blood
pressure has always been a problem for
an m10 pom also gives the students books
to read because the development of their
powers is directly related to their
personality development while in the
library namtan finds a file with the
names and occupations of every gifted
student that is passed from rita they
see that almost all of them are working
in multinational companies and are
highly successful palm also turns out to
be one of the students who belonged to
gifted program batch three suddenly pang
notices a page from the file is missing
that seems to have contained information
about student number five namtan uses
her power to see that the page had the
name and picture of a man named non
weirdly no significant detail about him
is mentioned they ask mr palm in the
next class and find out that non
resigned from the program because he
couldn't keep up with the others upon
seeing that namtan is interested in
non-story pom takes her to the storeroom
and hands her a box full of non's
belongings later that day namtan wears
his glasses and walks down the hallway
looking at the world from nan's point of
view pang's room used to be his where
she finds out he wanted to be an
astronaut and was very good at math this
makes her suspicious of mr palm's story
because someone like nan would not have
a hard time keeping up with his peers
pom notices that namtan's health is
deteriorating day by day he asks her to
stop using her powers for a few days but
she is too invested in nan's case to
listen pang helps her to get more info
on him by going through the official
school documents that the students are
restricted to see they find paperwork
that confirms that nan did resign from
the program however when namtan touches
the paper she sees that the pen that
signed it belonged to mr palm it is
clear that he was the one who filled the
form not non namtan also finds out that
the last time pom met shinnon was in the
school's warehouse the next day she goes
to the warehouse with pang and asks him
to pick the lock for her when he does
she locks herself inside using chain on
glasses and jacket she is able to see
what happened when he was last here he
has a red file with something very
crucial about the school because of it
he was restrained by a group of men so a
woman could steal the file before namtan
can see further her blood pressure rises
and she gets dizzy just then pang enters
the room and finds her on the ground
before passing out she tells him that
chanan found out about the school's
secret in the next scene namtan is at
the hospital with her mother palm and
pang her mother wants her to withdraw
from the program because it is harming
her health however pang convinces her
otherwise in the last scene everyone is
in the classroom pang suddenly remembers
what namtan told him in the warehouse
and asks her what truth she was talking
about to his surprise she says that
nothing happened in the warehouse as
soon as she stepped in she passed out
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching